of those of you sitting here are we just
waiting for cop hide copies of the bill
itself and we'll be starting momentarily
thank you for your patience okay so
there's two Senate
hearings yeah these are the four things
okay that's what I'm missing one of
those uh there here here's the pile with
all of them and they're both there so
whichever when you don't have you
can
confusing a game at summer camp that was
like that this shows you how invaluable
Christina is she when she's homesick we
we really miss
her
and thank you for being here um this is
the subcommittee on Senate Bill 236 it's
a retained bill out of the committee on
Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs uh as as stated in the bill
itself it's an act establishing a
committee to study nonprofit
organizations Contracting with the
Department of Health and Human Services
for children's
services um is anyone here to speak on
the bill or does anyone want to
comment representative
Weber I think I'd very much like to talk
among ourselves first because this is
not a public hearing it's a public
meeting um and what I wanted to say just
as as a by introduction is the bill is
limited not in its title but in its in
its uh body with respect to insurance
coverage and we had a great deal of very
compelling testimony at the original
hearing which spoke to the uh difficult
that some organizations which provide
much needed services in the state are
having getting insurance coverage at a
rate that they can afford and they're
supplying critical Services usually to
very vulnerable uh
populations so
um I will just State my own position I
don't know why we didn't just pass this
and get the work
started last turn but um I I have no
objection to hearing from to hearing
from people but uh it seems to me that
um you know the if if there is more to
say that's great but I just don't want
to sort of start the public hearing
process all over again from square one
okay thank you thank you representative
wber any other committee members sub
committee members want to comment before
we hear from someone else
or good okay I'm sorry you you were
about to up please
do good morning good morning my name is
Emily Lawrence and I am the deputy
advocacy director with Waypoint and
Waypoint was working with Senator
Chanley on bringing this bill forward um
in result because of the concerns for
our ISO Foster Care Program Waypoint
runs a small ISO Foster Care Program
which provides wound Services um for
children with some of the most intensive
needs these are some of our most
vulnerable children involved in the
child welfare system and this service
provides them with the opportunity to
remain um hopefully in their home
communities or at least in their home
state and get community-based Services
um it's an alternative to sending kids
to residential facilities which as you
may know the state is really trying to
move away from doing that and serve
children in their own communities
unfortunately we've had um issues as
that's why the bill came forward with um
our insurance we've lost our umbrell
policy we currently do have a million
doll liability policy um we know that in
the unfortunate event that we were
involved in a case that sometimes those
damages are much greater um and often
entities will will go after the
nonprofits um because the state has a
cap so it's not that they don't go after
the state as well but um and so we did
look around our we've had our broker
looking for Alternatives we were able to
get a quote from birkshire hathway for
our eight bed program it was double the
cost of what we pay for the entirety of
all of our other programs so that's
really not a sustainable affordable
option for us and while we are a small
program we're one of many that will be
affected by this
so unfortunately we're afraid that it
would be kind of like death by a
Thousand Cuts of these little programs
that provide these really critical
services and as it is we don't have
enough of them in the state um as you
may have seen the office of the child
Advocates recent report on children that
were sent um to a residential facility
in Tennessee there were really um
unfortunate concerns with their care
there and we were lucky to bring them
home but the reason that they were sent
there is that we can't find appropriate
care in the state because we don't have
that and we are working on building it
up but it is these critical services
that we need um we also met we did meet
with the insurance commissioner and his
staff who are here um to discuss this
issue we know this is something that
they are looking at as well and talking
with some of the um National entities
looking at this issue we are not opposed
to different options we just want to
make sure that it is examined and we can
figure out a solution to this because
from a business perspective alone it's
not sustainable for us to continue and
um as it is the only insurer right now
that ensures these types of
organizations is
Philadelphia um as you all know there is
a large lawsuit against the senuna Youth
Services Center and in that lawsuit over
100 other entities have been named and
almost all of them have Philadelphia for
their insur so the likelihood that
Philadelphia may start pulling back
which they have done I I believe in New
York they've completely withdrawn from
coverage of some of these programs um is
real and in that instance there would be
nothing for us so um and and we're
required by the state to maintain um
insurance as well in order to to do
these contracted
Services okay thank
you questions from committee members or
com
comments that gave a good overview thank
you
sure thank you thank you so much for
your time oh I will I'll just share that
last year in um West Virginia they
passed a law that um required all um its
child placing agencies which when I read
the definition would be akin to what
Waypoint does um to to maintain a mill
million dollar or more insurance policy
no less than a million and then they
allowed um they they were uh put in
statute that they would have a limit of
liability up to their insurance
amount so yeah question sure
representative kushman what is the diff
what is can you tell me what umbrella
coverage versus liability coverage yeah
I can tell you my limited knowledge I'm
not um so for example we have um
liability coverage is your base coverage
for ISS ues and then umbrella covers if
it's going to go above that so it's
almost like an extra layer and perhaps
someone else could explain it better but
that's my understanding of it thank
you any other questions for I'm sorry
ma'am uh what was your last name it's
Lawrence l l yep R nce yes okay great
and uh Deputy advocacy director for
Waypoint yes okay excellent thank you
thank you thank you very much for being
here this
morning would either of you folks in the
audience like to testify I know you Ser
from the Department of Insurance and you
gave us a letter from the commissioner
but uh I don't know if you want to you
know elaborate on that at all
or um sure I can elaborate on that uh my
name is James Fox under property and
Cassy director at the New Hampshire
insurance department this is Emily dhy
she's the property and Cas the attorney
at the Department um as to your question
uh about umbrella Insurance like if you
have a homeowner's policy that's your
your your primary layer of insurance and
then if you're if you have assets you
you know you want to protect assets
above what they'll sell you as a primary
layer so then you buy an umbrella layer
and that that basically is an umbrella
over all of your coverages that you have
so it's just a it's a higher level uh
higher layer of insurance so it kicks in
at like the $1 million level where your
whatever you buy and it's usually
cheaper so people usually do buy an
umbrella policy um uh
as to uh as to the bill um the the
department has also looked at the issue
of nonprofits ability to purchase
insurance as a general matter uh the
hard the markets are hardening which
means it's harder to get insurance um it
has a lot to do with uh property losses
across the country and then reinsurers
pulling back from having reinsurance and
if you know the Frontline insurers are
you know the ones you know am those
companies and then above that are the
reinsurers who basically insure the
insurance companies and so there's less
reinsurance out there so there's less
capacity to sell so then ultimately the
the market hardens so it's harder to
find coverages now in some areas we're
not as worried about that but I know the
commissioner in this particular area for
nonprofits due to the critical Services
they provide he is concerned about it
and uh he is uh committed to um
attempting to find a solution by working
with all the stakeholders um if there is
a subcommittee we absolutely would be uh
here to support the sub committee and
provide as much information as we can um
so we did submit a letter uh which are
the actual commissioner's words so uh I
would rely on that letter but I would
say uh the department is 100% not
opposed to this and we are we would be
um a active participant in in the
subcommittee to try to find um a
solution um that works for everyone from
industry to the nonprofits sure the
commissioner's comment is basically on
supportive of the concept he said that I
do believe it would be beneficial to
have a structured group of stakeholders
and policy makers to join us to form a
strategy to move forward so I that says
a lot
correct uh any questions from committee
members okay thank you well thank you
very much for being here thank you for
this this letter and information y
representative
Weber I just had a comment based on all
of that um
I see no problem with the bill as
drafted I think that one of the things
we might want to suggest to the
speaker is that in appointing the two
members of the House of
Representatives uh I would very much
hope that one of them came from the
Commerce Committee which has a great
deal more
experience with
um with insurance issues and
I frankly have no idea why this bill
came to us because the underlying issue
of children's services tend to go to the
children and family law committee so if
there was to be a change I would suggest
that we specified two members of the
House Representatives appointed by the
Speaker of the House one from Commerce
and one from children and family law but
if the members of the subcommittee don't
feel that that specificity is necessary
I I I don't insist on it I just make it
as a suggestion and it could be as
simple as an informal suggestion to the
speaker that's not uncommon right to
specify what where members on a
particular study committee should come
from no they they they do specify
sometimes and and sometimes they don't
okay but this one seems particularly to
be outside of the Health and Human
Services baileywick it it the children
and family law tend to deal with
Juvenile Justice matters and juvenile
protection matters and the Commerce
Committee tends to deal with insurance
matters and I have
seen uh the uh Mr Fox spoke of a whole
bunch of stakeholders and I have seen
very very effective small
committees uh that
have assembled all of the relevant
stakeholders in front of them and taken
their their testimony and their input so
I don't see the need for a gigantic
commission which is nowhere near as
Nimble as a committee and will take much
longer to set up I think I think we
should keep this
structure and and either leave it as it
is or be it slightly more
specific okay representative kushman
thank you Mr chairman I'm in total agree
um with you representative Weber um I
don't think we even need an amendment I
think if we you know even put it in
report that we recommend um you know
once the bill comes out of the full
committee um that those two members
that's that's completely
appropriate okay thank you thank you
representative n any comment I'm in
agreement with what has been said thank
you
okay representative wber I would make a
motion I would make a motion if you're
ready to receive one Mr chairman
absolutely um I would move that this
subcommittee recommend ought to pass on
Senate Bill 236 and make that
recommendation to the full committee and
uh along with representative kushman I
recommend that we put in our report that
the committee recommends somebody from
children and family law and somebody
from uh Commerce but that will be at the
discretion of the
speaker okay a motion has been made is
there a second to represent
representative
not okay is there any other discussion
on this
motion okay all those in favor I do we
don't need a roll call for something
like this to we or no not usually I
thought we needed a roll call the final
thing okay all right um there are only
four of us here so is it unanimous I do
I need to call of all
I I think if you just specify that it
was that the members were pulled and it
was unanimous if that's helpful I I
think we need a record of who is here
because representative TZ is not sure
yeah and I I've been making some notes
here so you'd use the full committee
sheet I guess um that's the only I think
that if you just want to write in your
notes that okay all right the four of us
were present and all four of us voted
yes
okay
okay excellent so uh again the record
will reflect that um the committee
subcommittee is unanimous and its um
vote on moving out to pass on Senate
Bill
236 uh any other discussion or any other
business to come before the subcommittee
relevant to this
bill if not I will close this hearing I
will suppose this meeting again thank
you to our um uh the folks uh in the
audience for attending this morning and
thank you for your input and U we are
Jed thank you for
being